all right in this video I'm going to
show you how to change the key battery
for a Honda CRV this is batteries used
from 2014 to present in the physical key
so you flip the key over you can see
there's a really small screw on the
backside of a key now to get this out
you're gonna need a very small
screwdriver so I have a precision
screwdriver here I said also known as
kind of like a jeweler set you I got
this for four bucks you can find these
on Amazon I'll link to it below the
video here but the real handy here
because you do need a very small
screwdriver to get this this screw out
so let me just get this out real quick
the first time you do this it can be
difficult I've already losing this one
so it's gonna be pretty easy for me here
but the first time you do this you may
have to press down really hard to get to
get some traction into that screw okay
so go ahead and pop that thing off and
then if you look at the side of the key
fob there's kind of a little notch if
you take a flathead screwdriver right
into that notch and twist I'll give you
some some leverage to be able to pop off
the two sections of the fob and once you
get that apart and it'll come apart
pretty easily so don't worry about
breaking anything there as long as you
stay in the notch and kind of twist
around it'll be good to get this part so
now you can see we have access to the
pad right in here just take our flat
head just gently pop out let's see our
1623 volt coin battery so once you have
a new one of these just make sure the
positive side is facing down and push it
in kind of keep it towards the top here
when you first push it in because
there's kind of some prongs down at the
bottom so let's make it easier once
you've got that in make sure that you
don't see any positive signs or
lettering facing you so you got the
right side in there and then go ahead
and reassemble the table just place
those two pieces back together and it'll
snap together real nice and easy and
then go ahead and replace your little
little baby screw and that's it so
that's how you change the key fob
battery for a Honda CRV